ok io come mi ha introdotto adoro
viaggiare voi
immagino la maggior parte di voi almeno
credo che in qualche modo siano
appassionati no dei viaggi e quindi ho
avuto una fortuna così di di coadiuvare
un pochino grazie al lavoro che faccia
l'esperienza che ho fatto che faccio nel
mio business di organizzare un viaggio
che che ha avuto come tema di fondo la
sostenibilità quindi la mobilità
alternativa e la nutrizione anche da un
punto di vista sostenibile quindi
organizzato un viaggio che è durato due
mesi adesso andremo a vedere nei
prossimi minuti
che cosa è stato questo viaggio però poi
alla fine forse la mia idea piano piano
è cresciuta sempre di più perché ho
messo insieme questi temi è diventato
anche un record mondiale ha parlato di
ecologia di mobilità sostenibile di
leadership perché si è creato un gruppo
siamo partiti in 8 la squadra verrà
fatta di otto persone era poi un sogno
che ho realizzato
quindi sono tanti temi che che potrei
toccare per raccontarvi questo viaggio
però la fine oggi ho deciso di cercare
di focalizzarmi su un aspetto
fondamentale che tra l'altro mi sta
diventando molto utile nel senso da
quando sono tornato da questo viaggio
sta mi sta facendo fare meglio nella
vita quotidiana e la passione che a dir
la verità ultimamente avevo anche un po
perso nel quotidiano nelle cose nel mio
lavoro di tutti i giorni e con questo
seguendo questo sogno questo progetto ho
ritrovato eccola la necessità di dover
tenere quotidianamente avere sempre a
mente quelli che sono le nostre passioni
cerca di coltivarle non mettere nel
cassetto
allora che cosa quello è stata l'idea
partire io personalmente abito a
shanghai da qualche anno e dove appunto
avendo iniziato una nuova attività
lavorativa non potevo non ho avuto il
tempo di coltivare la mia passione
quindi dopo qualche anno di così di
repressione delle passioni ho deciso di
prendermi due mesi sabbatici e dire
tornerò a milano in moto ma non
semplicemente in moto ho deciso di
tornarci con una moto elettrica a loro
per un filo lungo 12.000 km
no non è andata così ecco questo è stato
questo è il progetto che adesso andremo
a vedere un po come come si sa si è
costruito ho preparato
ecco questi sessanta secondi ci hanno
dato per un brevissimo tassi di quello
che è stato il progetto un'idea che è
nata una sera ho deciso così ho deciso
di fare questo viaggio è l'inizio
pensavo di fare una cosa in autonomia
e proprio pensando come stanno
ragionando questo a questo progetto ho
cercato di in grandi un po lo scopo di
cercare di coinvolgere anche il tema non
solo del della mobilità alternativa per
cercare di capire se effettivamente i
mezzi del futuro possano essere a
trazione elettrica o ibrida eccetera
ho deciso anche di misurare siamo di
sperimentare durante il viaggio cercare
di valutare e studiare le varie culture
alimentari delle undici nazioni che
abbiamo attraversato quindi con con
l'università di bari che un centro di
eccellenza nel in quella che si chiama
lca life cycle assessment la misurazione
dell'impatto ambientale di un prodotto
agroalimentare dalla sua diciamo dalla
sua origine agricola gricoltura fino
alla forchetta quindi fin dove arriva
quindi abbiamo messo insieme a questi
temi è piaciuto moltissimo progetto ad
expo milano che proprio ha come tema la
nutrizione e la sostenibilità 15 anno ci
hanno supportato e da lì siamo partiti
noi si è creato ho messo insieme una
squadra
questo progetto lo portava avanti nei
ritagli di tempo quindi tantissime notti
insonni perché ho iniziato organizzarlo
sei mesi prima della partenza siamo
partiti a giugno e siamo arrivati a
milano a fine
a fine luglio quindi ci ho messo circa
sei mesi organizzare questo progetto è
stato un lavoro veramente faticoso la
preparazione sta forse l'aspetto più più
difficile anche perché partendo dalla
cina ci sono tantissimi aspetti
burocratici che sono molto molto
complessi siamo partiti finalmente lo
sforzo anche in viaggio è stata notevole
perché siamo stati si stava mediamente
in viaggio circa 8 9 ore al giorno in
sella alle nostre moto e ed è stata
un'esperienza magnifica magnifica piena
di problemi tantissimi problemi grandi
anche difficoltà legate alla squadra
alla squadra che ho reclutato grazie a
internet
io mi trovavo in cina ho creato questo
sito web
ho scritto chi cercavo e chi volesse
condividere dell'avventura con me
non vi dico quante persone hanno hanno
fatto questa applicazione
quindi alla fine ho scelto questo team
che era composto da da un fotografo da
un meccanico da un blogger da un
operatore video insomma era abbastanza
consistente è però non ci conoscevamo
immaginatevi partiti alla volta di un
viaggio così epico di fatto non ci
eravamo mai incontrati quindi uno degli
aspetti molto difficile cerco di toccare
quegli aggettivi che ho usato all'inizio
discorso di leadership avendo io ho
organizzato questo questo viaggio dovevo
in qualche modo anche appunto gestire
questa questa squadra che di fronte così
a queste difficoltà anche perché siamo
stati in paesi piuttosto difficili la
mongolia in primis e
è assolutamente un paese dove richiede
una certa organizzazione per a trattare
il quel territorio che è un territorio
dove non ci sono strade quindi difficile
in più noi avevamo dei mezzi che erano
di fatto non tradizionali avevamo questo
queste moto motociclette elettriche
quindi tanta tensione nel nella squadra
queste sono alcune immagini che fanno
capire un po la la fatica e quanti
problemi avevamo quotidianamente da
affrontare tecnicamente di orientamento
ma anche di digestione del appunto della
relazione perché stando sempre insieme
24 ore al giorno le dinamiche e proprio
di di redazione sono molto complicate
sono stati degli aspetti dei momenti
molto critici ma la cosa bella la cosa
molto interessante in questo un po ma
una foto che invece fa vedere un momento
più sereno
quanto più siamo entrati nella parte più
difficile è tosta di questo viaggio che
era proprio il deserto mongolo quindi
dove c'è una che condizioni molto
difficili 45 gradi di temperatura
insomma magicamente tutto iniziato a
funzionare meglio
un po come se la
come dire la paura e rischio di dover
sopravvivere perché comunque è chiaro
che in quel contesto è viene viene fuori
l'istinto di sopravvivenza magicamente
le dinamiche della squadra si sono si
sono come un ingranaggio garda
funzionare alla perfezione è stato un
grandissimo insegnamento che che mi
serve che mi sono portato a casa e
mi ha fatto sicuramente crescere oltre
poi al alla disponibilità e aiuti che
vanno trovato per la strada anche
famiglie poverissime perché la mongolia
ci sono questi nomadi che vivono giusto
del degli animali che allevano quindi
non hanno quasi nulla però sono sempre
stati molto molto ospitali con noi e e e
poi c'era l'aspetto della nutrizione in
questi 44 giorni non abbiamo mai
mangiato qualcosa che non fosse locale
un cibo locale quindi abbiamo avuto
un'esperienza alimentare un po estrema
quasi tutti hanno avuto dei problemi
anche di stomaco
però in questo modo si è permesso di
documentare abbiamo fatto tutto un
documentazione fotografica che verrà poi
utilizzata l'expo di milano per
raccontare attraverso proprio le culture
attraverso quello che che è un po la
nutrizione e quello che sono le
abitudini alimentari di ognuno di questo
di questi pasti che abbiamo fatto in
questi 44 giorni abbiamo poi analizzato
quelle che fossero le l'impatto
ambientale cioè quali sono le diete che
sono buone per noi ma buone anche per il
pianeta e sono venuti fuori dei dati
molto molto interessante una ricerca
come dicevo che abbiamo sviluppato
insieme all'università di bari e quindi
con una valenza anche scientifica e
stiamo elaborando adesso questa massa di
dati che abbiamo portato a casa e anche
questo verrà poi
sfruttato durante l'expo dell'anno ormai
diciamo fra un anno praticamente e
quindi potete vedere chi siamo dovuti
adattare a mangiare quello che trovavamo
assolutamente sulla strada buono cattivo
o comunque in certi casi soprattutto in
cina abbiamo avuto anche delle cose che
non sono poi così facile da mandare giù
però un'esperienza un'esperienza
grandiosa un'esperienza che che
sicuramente non è non è così facile da
ripetere perché ovviamente viaggiare un
viaggio inteso come con un'estensione
anche di tempo così così lunga non è
facile da organizzare e deve avere deve
avere quello che il un bene
preziosissimo che il tempo è stato molto
fortunato potermi gestire il mio tempo
per poter riprendere questi due mesi e
per coronare così questo questo sogno
però io già sto pensando al prossimo
ecco fatta la prima viene già in mente
cos'altro si possa fare di difficoltà
poi ne abbiamo avute diverse anche da un
punto di vista tecnologico appunto
adesso vi brevemente vi accenno il
perché tipo di mezzi abbiamo usato come
detto erano delle moto elettriche
avete visto nel nelle foto che c'erano
anche delle automobili che trasportavano
il resto dell'equipaggio quindi una
delle prime domande che tutti fanno bene
perché avete usato dalle moto elettriche
poi delle auto seguito che bruciavano
benzina è verissimo però appunto ho
cercato un cavo lungo 12 chi 12.000
chilometri ma non l'ho trovato quindi ho
deciso di portare delle auto dietro che
potessero aiutarci a a trasportare
l'energia necessaria per questi per
alimentare queste motociclette
elettriche che veniva prodotta da dei
pannelli solari installati su queste
macchine e poi anche dalla rete quindi
ci siamo alimentati dove era possibile
anche dalla rete
comunque sia il viaggio è stato poi
analizzato è misurato da un punto di
vista delle emissioni di co2 e siamo
riusciti a ridurre il nostro impatto
di co2 rispetto al un viaggio con con
dei veicoli tradizionali a combustione
comunque è stato da meno della metà del
56 per cento in meno quindi sicuramente
l'obiettivo di fare un avventura
ecologica l'abbiamo centrato
e chiaro che
questi mezzi sono i vincoli di queste di
queste nuove tecnologie sono molto
legati appunto alla disponibilità di una
rete energetica
però quello che io volevo provare era
dimostrare che ci sono delle alternative
la tecnologia in questo senso sta
facendo dei passi avanti notevoli e in
qualche modo abbiamo testato
nell'estremo che è possibile muoversi
con con dei mezzi che abbattano
decisamente l'impatto ambientale
quindi andiamo siamo tornati a casa dopo
44 giorni con un ottimo e grandissimo
benvenuto all'expo di milano è stata un
viaggio perfetto se avevate avevo fatto
una tabella di marcia e siamo arrivati
esattamente il giorno in cui era
previsto dopo 44 giorni quindi
l'esperienza andata perfettamente è
stato un successo tanto che appunto
vorrei ripetere qualcosa di simile in
futuro mantenendo appunto questi due
temi fondamentali gli diciamo di
un'avventura ecologica che si svolge
attraverso il viaggio con mezzi veicoli
a zero oa basso impatto ambientale e per
documentare le abitudini alimentari dei
paesi attraversati
ovviamente dopo aver avuto le
celebrazioni di arrivo tutti contenti
tutto bene al lavoro via tornato in cina
è però appunto questo è un altro aspetto
interessante perché come dicevo prima
mia non ho perso due mesi di lavoro ma
credo invece di avere fatto
un'esperienza che mi serve molto anche
nel quotidiano non solo perché
qualcos'altro di nuovo da raccontare ma
ma anche perché appunto a livello di
esperienza di
di team building di gestione delle
relazioni con queste persone eccetera
sono stati tanti
tanti elementi che che mi hanno fatto
imparare delle cose nuove
oltre che ad aver ri stimo risvegliato
la passione e che come dicevo per un
qualche anno avevo dovuto mettere da
parte e devo dire che tornare al lavoro
con con questo background di stimoli mi
mi sta dando una motivazione in più per
per dare il meglio anche nel
nel nel mio business e quindi non mi
resta che a questo punto dirvi buon
viaggio e vi auguro appunto di poter
inseguire i vostri sogni e di coltivare
le vostre passioni che sono la cosa più
importante